here's why Pascal was slinging shade at
Coen at the Emmys the viewers of the
75th prime time Emmy Awards may have
done a double take when Pedro Pascal
showed up with his arm in a sling but
they did a triple take when he called
out Kieran cin completely out of the
blue Pascal took to the podium to
present an award and opened by saying
before we get into the nominees for best
supporting actor in a drama series I'd
like to take just a second to make this
about me a lot of people have been
asking about my arm the broadcast
censored the punch line of it story but
the insensitive clip on YouTube
clarified what he said Pascal continued
it's actually my shoulder and I think
this is a perfect time to tell everyone
that Kier and coin beat the on me
immediately after the cameras treated
viewers to a closeup of a stone-faced
Cen staring at Pascal audiences got a
laugh and a few seconds later coin
cracked a smile as well